okay so the topic of this presentation
is going to be some of the basic
chemistry behind water let's go ahead
and get started
so one of the more defining features of
water is that it's a polar molecule and
this means that one part of the molecule
has a positive charge while the other
has a negative charge now you know the
formula for water is H2O so there's an O
for oxygen and the periodic table oxygen
has eight protons and also means it has
eight electrons
and therefore they kind of cancel out
and you have no charge I'm going to draw
the eight electrons of oxygen there's
going to be two electrons in level one
and six electrons in the second level
now water is also made from hydrogen
atoms and so I'm going to add one to
hydrogen atoms hydrogen has one proton
in its nucleus and then one electron in
its outer level so by themselves all
three of these atoms are unstable but
they also have no charge all three of
them
however when water forms
the two hydrogens will bond with the
oxygen
so now that the atoms have bonded let's
focus our attention on the red oxygen
atom what we're going to see is that it
really Hogs the blue electrons of
hydrogen let me go ahead and put the red
electrons in motion and what happens is
the oxygen atom will actually kind of
take the blue hydrogen electrons and by
doing so this is how oxygen becomes
negatively charged it has eight protons
but it has 10 electrons giving it a
negative charge and this is how the blue
hydrogen atoms become positively charged
the blue hydrogens still have their one
proton but they don't have any electrons
making them positive and you can see
we've fulfilled the definition of what
it means to be polar one part positive
one part negative
so let me freeze the electrons and
remind us that a covalent bond is when
the involved atoms share electrons an
ionic bond is where one atom takes
electrons from another you might think
this is an ionic bond because it looks
like oxygen is taking electrons from the
hydrogen atoms however we're going to
see it's a covalent bond because every
now and then a couple of electrons will
orbit around the hydrogen on the right
and every now and then a couple
electrons will orbit around the
hydrogens on the left but most of the
time the electrons are orbiting around
the oxygen so the definition of covalent
bonds is fulfilled because they do share
electrons it's just not shared equally
so here's a simpler picture of a water
molecule bonding with another water
molecule and they bond in by what's
called a hydrogen bond here you see why
they bond positive hydrogen is attracted
to negative oxygens and when we add more
water molecules you can see a bunch of
hydrogen bonds are forming which hold
polar water molecules together
so here's a layer of water molecules and
what's underneath them are more water
molecules again positive connected to
negatives and what's underneath layer
number two is layer number three
underneath layer three well depends on
how deep the water is but notice how the
molecules are arranged positive to
negative because water is polar
so because water is polar there's a few
other characteristics one being that
water has a high specific heat and what
this means is that it will resist
changing temperatures it's not
impossible to change the temperature of
water you can boil it of course it just
takes a lot of energy to break the
hydrogen bonds
so here's a pot filled with water and if
we add a flame underneath over time what
happens is these hydrogen bonds begin to
be to be broken and the water begins to
evaporate but because water has a high
specific heat it just takes a lot of
energy to break these bonds eventually
they're broken and the water evaporates
so this is actually a really good thing
water having a high specific heat
because this helps to maintain our
constant internal body temperature you
know the mass of our bodies is mostly
water and even during strenuous activity
like the athletes in this picture are
our body temperature hardly changes
we've all had moments where we've had a
fever and we felt miserable and we've
been ill and sick and we don't feel very
well what's going on there well when our
normal body temperature of 98.6 degrees
Fahrenheit well we have proteins in our
body and here's a protein protein X but
in an elevated temperature the protein
begins to denature and unravel and so
when our body temperature becomes too
higher to low proteins within our body
start to break down and therefore our
cells lose the ability to perform
whatever function those proteins are
responsible for and it could lead to
some of the ill effects that we feel
when we're sick so maintaining a
constant internal body temperature is
really important it's a good thing we're
mostly made from water
so another characteristic of water is
that it has cohesion and because water
is polar it will be attracted to other
water molecules that are also polar you
know the paper clip that you see in this
picture it's not actually floating let's
explore this
so here's our our water and let me add a
paper clip and if I were to ask why is
this paperclip able to stay atop the
water it's not that really that it's
floating it's just that the paper clip
isn't heavy enough to break those
hydrogen bonds that we talked about
earlier that are connecting one water
molecule with another water molecule
for the same reason that you see in this
picture water Strider are insects that
can skip across the surface of water
here you can actually see where the legs
of the insect come in contact with the
water the water is kind of flexing and
bending underneath the weight of the
insect the insect is just not heavy
enough to break those hydrogen bonds but
because water is polar it will attract
with other water molecules and that's
what cohesion means
so because water is polar it also has
adhesion and this is where polar water
molecules are attracted to substances
other than water here's a graduated
cylinder filled with water notice the
curvature right there that's known as
the meniscus when you add water into a
graduated cylinder now the bottom of the
meniscus might read 25 milliliters and
the top might read let's say 29 well how
much water is inside of this graduated
cylinder do you read the top or the
bottom in order to be accurate you
always read the bottom of the meniscus
25 milliliters but the point is why is
there a meniscus in the first place
that's because water is polar and it's
attracted to the inside of the graduated
cylinder again this is just another good
example of how water has adhesion
so changing topics I want to mention
that water is one part of a solution you
might know a solution is simply a
mixture where one substance can dissolve
within another now Solutions tend to
have two parts to them one part being a
solvent and this is going to be the
watery part so the solvent is the part
of a solution that actually causes
things to dissolve and the things that
dissolve are called solutes we'll talk
about them in a moment and water is
typically the universal solvent and the
other part of a solution are called the
solutes that I just mentioned a moment
ago solutes are the parts that actually
dissolve and so if you put sugars into
water the sugars are going to dissolve
salts will dissolve when you put them in
water nutrients will dissolve when you
put them in water
so here's a beaker of water let me add
some sugar and some maybe strawberry
Kool-Aid powder and which makes sense
statement a sugar dissolves in water or
B water dissolves in Sugar statement a
should make sense the sugar in the
Kool-Aid is going to dissolve within the
water because the sugar are the solutes
the Kool-Aid is the solutes and the
water is the solvent
so a great example of a biological
solution is blood now here's a test tube
filled with blood and there's a stopper
on top and if we put it in a centrifuge
which is a machine that spins it really
fast it will separate into these layers
the bottom layer being red blood cells
the middle layer being white blood cells
and platelets and the beige liquid on
Top This is blood plasma plasma which is
mostly made up of water that makes
plasma the solvent portion of a solution
and suspended within that plasma are
solutes such as sugars and proteins and
salts so blood again just a really nice
example of a biological solution made up
of solutes and solvent
so let's change topic for a moment and
talk about the pH scale something you
might remember from middle school the
scale ranges between 0 to 14 you might
remember everything below a 7 is an acid
everything above a 7 is a base and if
something has a pH of exactly seven it's
neutral and this is really the pH of
water
but what is the pH scale actually
measure it measures the the
concentration of hydrogen ions that are
within a solution this is a little
backwards here but acids actually does
the smaller the number tend to have more
hydrogen ions and therefore the bases
even though they have the bigger numbers
have fewer hydrogen ions well bases
actually have a lot of another kind of
ion known as hydroxides and acids have
very few hydroxides
now what makes an acid or a base strong
is really the distance from neutral the
farther you go from neutral the stronger
the acid becomes and for a base the
the base becomes so if I add these
Solutions right here
and these questions take a moment pause
the video try to answer these I'm going
to go over the answers in three two one
so number one which base has the most
hydrogen ions I hope you said well
that's blood even though blood has a pH
of about 7.5 7.6 it's the the farthest
base that's to the left on the scale
number two what substance has the fewest
hydrogen ions well from the six that I
gave you it would be ammonia because
it's farthest to the right it's the
stronger of the bases and then number
three which of these is the strongest
acid well there's only three acids
lemons soft drinks and milk the
strongest acid is lemons it's the
smallest number but it's further from
neutral
so here's a couple beakers of water
let's go into acids and bases in a
little more detail acids first if I were
to drop a block of substance a into the
beaker on the left and over time
substance a dissolves and releases
hydrogen ions this would form an acidic
solution
on the right hand side focus on the
bases if I drop a block of substance B
and it slowly dissolves and releases
hydroxides this would be characteristic
of an alkaline or a basic solution
so let's connect the pH scale to to life
maintaining our pH inside of our bodies
is critical blood has a pH of about 7.4
which is a a weak base and here we have
two side-by-side tables here when our
proteins are exposed to the normal pH of
blood they maintain their shape and
these proteins can perform a variety of
functions in our cells but when exposed
to abnormal pH either too high or too
low proteins begin to denature and then
we lose whatever process these proteins
are part of so maintaining the the
internal balance like our pH is is
crucial to our survival
so one action that can actually alter
the pH of our blood is through alcohol
abuse alcohol poisoning can lower the ph
because as alcohol builds up hydrogen
ions build up in the person's
bloodstream this Alters the normal 7.4
pH found within their bloodstream and
when if protein X is supposed to
maintain this shape but because of the
lower than normal pH now it denatures
and begins to unravel again this protein
performs a function and as the protein
unravels this this function is now lost
now hopefully your kidneys will remove
these extra hydrogen ions and maybe the
worst thing that happens is you wake up
with a little bit of a headache if
you've ever drink too much too much
alcohol but unfortunately with people
who abuse alcohol often there's kidney
damage and so they have a hard time
regulating this balance
so as I wrap up this video here's a
practice quiz that you can try to check
your understanding I hope you found this
video helpful and thanks for watching